Wir sind hier in einer
riesigen Kaverne mitten im Berg,
in die man grosse Tanks
gestellt hat.
Hier hat der Bund reinen Alkohol,
also Ethanol, gelagert,
natürlich für Desinfektionszwecke.
* Bedrohlich anschwellende Musik *
(Französisch)
Wo war das Lager mit 10'000 t Ethanol
Anfang der Pandemie?
Dieses Lager
gab es leider nicht mehr.
Der Bund hat sich entschieden,
diese Lager nicht weiterzuführen.
Das war ein Fehlentscheid,
unverständlich.
Die grösste Sorge war immer:
Wenn wir plötzlich
kein Ethanol mehr haben,
laufen wir in eine Katastrophe.
Die FFP3- und FFP2-Masken habe ich
in der Baubranche eingekauft,
bei Maurern und Malern.
Man sollte eigentlich Masken tragen,
aber wir haben keine.
Der Kanton kann nicht liefern.
Hier hat das ganze System
komplett versagt.
Es ist jetzt nicht der Moment,
zurückzublicken,
was man in der Vergangenheit
verpasst hat, aufzubauen.
Bonjour.
Der Gesundheitsminister,
oberster Verantwortlicher
für die Pandemievorsorge.
Es ist keine perfekte Welt.
Wir mussten auf die Situation
reagieren, die eingetreten ist.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Es war plötzlich da.
Man hatte keinen Appetit mehr,
die Kraft war weg.
Man mochte nicht mehr gehen.
Schlimm war schon, dass mich
niemand mehr besuchen durfte.
Die Kinder ... Nur am Telefon,
sonst habe ich sie nicht gesehen.
Geht es?
Haben Sie etwas Schönes bekommen?
- Ja.
Die 87-jährige Rosa Neuhaus.
Nicht nur sie war am Virus erkrankt.
Fast jeder dritte Bewohner
hatte sich angesteckt,
hier im Pflegeheim Aergera
im Kanton Freiburg.
In den ersten Wochen der Krise
waren die Testkriterien streng:
Nur wer Fieber und Husten hatte,
wurde getestet, alle anderen nicht.
Man sagte einfach:
Isoliert die Leute.
D.h., man wusste gar nicht,
wer positiv ist und wer nicht?
Nein,
wir waren komplett im Blindflug.
Natürlich
verbreitete sich das Virus.
Wir hatten fünf Todesfälle,
einen im Zusammenhang mit COVID.
Die vier anderen wissen wir nicht,
weil wir ja nicht testen konnten.
Das war ein Ausnahmezustand.
Man kam frühmorgens,
ging spätabends nach Hause
und konnte nicht abschalten,
man wälzte es im Kopf.
Das geht an die Substanz.
Erst Ende April
wurden alle Heimbewohner getestet,
um das Ausmass des Ausbruchs
zu klären.
Auch die Desinfektionsmittel
waren knapp.
Unser Hauslieferant war ausverkauft.
Wir hatten das Glück,
dass gewisse Brauereien anfingen,
Desinfektionsmittel zu produzieren.
Dort konnten wir bestellen.
Wenn man täglich
x-mal die Hände desinfiziert,
leiden diese, wenn man nicht
Gel mit Schutzmittel nutzen kann.
Es hat alles etwas gelitten.
Haben Sie mitbekommen, dass der Bund
das Reservelager für Ethanol
ein Jahr vor der Krise aufgelöst hat?
Sch...
- Nämlich?
Scheisse, das hätte uns
definitiv geholfen. Definitiv.
Alcosuisse,
der grösste Importeur von Ethanol.
Es war teilweise wirklich dramatisch
und die Verfügbarkeit
war extrem angespannt.
Eine Ausnahmesituation,
wie ich sie noch nie erlebt habe.
Man war Tag und Nacht am Telefon.
Das war unglaublich stressig,
sehr viele Emotionen.
Frau Bauer, kommen Sie,
ich zeige es Ihnen.
Passen Sie auf die Schläuche auf.
Die sind zum Entladen.
Das ist der Zug, der heute
aus Frankreich gekommen ist.
Es ist Mitte Juni.
Florian Krebs ist der Geschäftsführer
von alcosuisse.
Ethanol ist Alkohol,
der Hauptbestandteil
für Desinfektionsmittel.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Hier haben wir eine Lieferung,
um den Mangel möglichst abzufedern.
Das ist Ethanol,
das normalerweise Treibstoff,
also Benzin, beigemischt wird.
Ist das nicht giftig?
Benzin ist giftig, das hier nicht.
Wir haben
einen Riesenaufwand betrieben,
um auf dem Weltmarkt
Chargen zu finden,
die 100%ig nicht
mit Benzin kontaminiert sind.
Vor fünf Monaten hätten wir uns
noch nicht vorstellen können,
solches Ethanol zu brauchen
für diesen Verwendungszweck.
Es brauchte eine Notverordnung
des Bundesamts für Gesundheit,
um aus dem minderwertigen Ethanol
Desinfektionsmittel
herstellen zu können.
Mittlerweile
ist es gesundheitlich unbedenklich,
aber der Geruch ist nicht so,
wie man ihn sich vorstellt.
Menschen,
denen der Geruch fremd ist,
könnten ihn
als muffig, dumpf beschreiben.
Wie kam es
zu dieser Ausnahmesituation?
Früher gehörte Florian Krebs'
alcosuisse dem Bund.
Auf Anfang 2019 aber
wurde der Ethanolmarkt liberalisiert.
Damit fiel
das Reservelager des Bundes weg.
Als Ersatz waren Pflichtlager
bei privaten Firmen in Diskussion.
Das war unsere Argumentation.
Wir haben versucht, aufzuzeigen,
wie wichtig die Lagervorhaltung
für ein Land wie die Schweiz ist.
Man ist zu 100 % abhängig
von Importen.
Nicht nur bei der Desinfektion, auch
bei der Medikamentenherstellung,
in der Lebensmittelindustrie
und -produktion,
für sehr viele relevante,
lebensnotwendige Bereiche.
Für uns stand ausser Frage,
dass wir Pflichtlager brauchen.
Verantwortlich ist
die wirtschaftliche Landesversorgung.
Das Bundesamt arbeitet zusammen
mit Fachleuten aus der Wirtschaft.
Sie entschieden: kein Pflichtlager.
Dabei schrieb das Amt noch
einen Monat vor der Liberalisierung,
Ethanol sei v.a.
im "Pandemiefall unentbehrlich".
Ein "lebensnotwendiges Gut".
Und: Der Prozess
für eine Pflichtlagerhaltung
werde "mit einem Antrag
an den Bundesrat
und einer Ämterkonsultation
Anfang 2019 gestartet".
Warum also die Kehrtwende?
Der zuständige Beamte
ist unterdessen pensioniert.
Zum Interview
erscheint ein Unternehmer.
Er gehört
zu den Fachleuten der Wirtschaft,
die über Pflichtlager beraten.
Ich bin nicht überzeugt,
ob es in einer Ämterkonsultation
mehrheitsfähig geworden wäre.
Allein die Revision des Alkohol-
gesetzes hat so lange gedauert.
Es wäre wohl
nicht erfolgreich gewesen,
dann beim Bund
ein Pflichtlager zu beantragen.
Sie meinen,
man habe es gar nicht versucht,
weil es mühsam geworden wäre?
Die Wirtschaft,
Hauptversorgerin der Schweiz,
war der Meinung,
es brauche keine Pflichtlager -
mit dem damaligen Verständnis
einer Pandemie.
Für uns verteilt sich eine Pandemie
relativ langsam über die ganze Welt,
sodass man
immer wieder Kontingente hat
und mehrere Lieferanten,
die liefern können.
Aber Pandemie heisst doch, dass Lie-
ferketten weltweit zusammenbrechen.
Wenn Sie
die absolute Sicherheit wollen,
und für alle Eventualitäten
vorsorgen wollen,
kann sich das
keine Organisation leisten.
Man muss den Mut
zu gewissen Lücken haben.
Wer entscheidet hier?
Laut Gesetz ist die Landesversorgung
zuerst Aufgabe der Wirtschaft.
Die Organisation teilt sich auf:
in ein kleines Bundesamt
und eine grosse Milizorganisation
von Wirtschaftsvertretern.
Rund 250 Fachleute
machen Vorgaben für Pflichtlager,
über die der Bundesrat entscheidet.
Bisher ist er den Vorgaben
der Wirtschaft immer gefolgt.
Die 34 Beamten fungieren nur
als Sekretariat der Wirtschaftsmiliz.
Ohne Zustimmung der Fachleute
können sie keine Pflichtlager
in die Wege leiten.
Auch der Chef der Landesversorgung,
ein sog. Delegierter,
muss aus der Privatwirtschaft
stammen.
Das Bundesamt
führt er nur im Nebenamt.
Lohnen sich die Pflichtlager?
Grundsätzlich lohnt sich kein Lager
für die Wirtschaft.
Sie arbeitet Richtung null Lager,
auf allen Produktionsketten.
Dann ist das Bundesamt
für wirtschaftliche Landesversorgung
am Gängelband der Wirtschaft,
die aus Eigeninteresse sagt,
sie wolle keine Pflichtlager,
weil sie sich nicht lohnen.
Die Wirtschaft und das Bundesamt
arbeiten gut zusammen,
auch in dieser Krise.
Das hat man gesehen ...
- Aber meine Frage ist:
Wenn eine Krise ausbricht,
der Markt nicht mehr spielt,
nützt der Glaube an den freien Markt
nichts.
Es ist ein Widerspruch in sich,
wenn die sich
von der Wirtschaft leiten lassen,
wenn es um Vorsorge geht.
Wenn wir Richtung Planwirtschaft
gehen, wird es nicht besser.
Und wie beurteilen
die Wirtschaftsexperten
ihren Ethanol-Entscheid heute?
Heute denke ich,
es war ein suboptimaler Entscheid.
Wir sind auch dabei,
diesen Entscheid zu revidieren.
Wenig Desinfektionsmittel,
zu wenig Masken und Schutzkittel.
Die Folge der Ansteckungen
im Pflegeheim Aergera:
Zwangsquarantäne.
Zehn Tage lang durfte niemand mehr
das Zimmer verlassen.
Kranke wie Rosa Neuhaus
waren noch viel länger eingesperrt.
Nein, es war nicht einfach.
Es war eine seltsame Zeit,
man wusste nicht,
ob Frühling oder Winter ist.
Man musste zwischendurch überlegen,
welcher Tag ist.
(TV) Der Salat war sehr gut.
Es gibt hier natürlich auch Leute,
die das nicht verstehen,
nach 5 Min. wieder vergessen haben,
was wir ihnen gesagt haben.
Manchmal schimpften sie
oder es flossen Tränen.
Oder es gab Verzweiflung:
"Was soll das alles werden?"
Es gibt natürlich auch
Medikamente zur Beruhigung.
Die mussten wir manchmal
auch einsetzen.
* Melancholische Klavierakkorde *
* Rhythmische Dance-Musik:
"Rock It" von Ofenbach *
# You are my reason to believe.
(Simonetta Sommaruga)
Für Reisende aus Risikogebieten
gilt eine Quarantänepflicht, wenn
sie in die Schweiz zurückkehren.
(Alain Berset)
Die betroffenen Personen
müssen sich eigenverantwortlich
in Quarantäne begeben.
Es ist aber selbstverständlich klar:
Es wird nicht möglich sein,
all diese Personen zu finden
und zu kontrollieren.
Grüezi, darf ich fragen,
woher Sie gerade kommen?
Serbien.
- Was tun Sie in den nächsten Tagen?
Äh ... Ich bin nicht sicher,
ich weiss es nicht.
Quarantäne?
- Ich glaube schon, ja.
* Telefon *
Guten Tag,
Heilbronn vom Kantonsarztamt Bern.
Ja, gestern hiess es vom BAG noch,
man müsse rückwirkend
in Quarantäne gehen.
Das wurde geändert
und gilt ab heute nicht mehr.
Stellte sich für Sie
auch die Sinnfrage,
als Schweden plötzlich
nicht mehr auf der Liste war?
Definitiv.
Ist das ein Quarantänefall?
Kroatien ist auf der Liste, oder?
- Nein.
Okay.
Quarantänen-Chaos.
... schon sehr ernst zu nehmen.
Die Kantonsarztämter
kontaktieren die Infizierten.
Sie müssen herausfinden,
wo sie sich angesteckt
und wem sie das Virus
übertragen haben.
Wir sind hier
auf der Startmaske von SORMAS.
SORMAS: eine neue Software,
um Kontakte zu erfassen.
SORMAS ist aber nur e i n System,
die Kantone nutzen fünf verschiedene.
Untereinander
sind sie nicht vernetzt.
Es ist ein riesiger Zusatzaufwand.
Wünschen Sie sich
ein Schweizer System?
Ja, selbstverständlich.
Das würde es massiv vereinfachen.
Wissen Sie,
was im Pandemieplan steht?
Nein, das weiss ich nicht.
- Es gibt ein schweizweites System.
Es heisst IES,
vom Koordinierten Sanitätsdienst.
Mhm.
Schon mal gehört?
- Nein, das sagt mir nichts.
Wir sind
eine ausführende Organisation.
Wir arbeiten mit dem,
was uns das BAG, das Kantonsarztamt
oder wer auch immer
zur Verfügung stellt.
Das System IES ...
Genau.
- Es ist bezahlt, es ist da.
Gewisse Kantone nutzen das auch.
Das System ist relativ komplex.
Ich muss vielleicht sagen: Ich kann
nicht aus eigener Erfahrung reden.
Wir nutzen es nicht.
Ich habe gehört,
es sei ein psychologisches Problem.
Der Entwickler des Programms,
der Koordinierte Sanitätsdienst,
sei in vielen Kantonen nicht beliebt.
Es braucht sicher weitere Klärung:
Was ist die Aufgabe,
wie ist die Zusammenarbeit?
* Bedrohliche pulsierende Klänge *
Bereit?
Okay.
... und an die Kantone.
Wir haben das Gefühl,
in gewissen Bereichen,
z.B. beim Contact Tracing, bei
der telefonischen Nachverfolgung,
könnte man durchaus einen
zentralen Ansatz haben. Fertig.
Ein Amt, das kaum jemand kennt.
Kommen Sie herein.
- Vielen Dank.
Wer ist eigentlich der KSD?
Eine zivile Funktion in der Armee,
im Verteidigungsdepartement.
Vom Militär?
- Vom Militär.
Aber die Koordinationsfunktion
ist natürlich schwierig.
Hier also wurde das schweizweite
Contact-Tracing-Programm IES
entwickelt.
Im Auftrag
des Bundesamts für Gesundheit.
Seit acht Jahren schon
gibt es diese Software.
Kostenpunkt: eine halbe Million.
Wir erwarteten,
dass das BAG dahintersteht
und es bei den Kantonen lanciert.
Wir mussten feststellen,
dass sich das BAG von gewissen
Kantonen beeinflussen liess.
Sie wurden aber auch nicht
richtig geschult auf dem System.
Es wurde das Gefühl vermittelt,
das System sei kompliziert,
mit Passwort usw.
D.h., der Bund hat eine halbe Million
Franken Steuergelder
aus dem Fenster geworfen.
Zumindest hat es wohl dazu geführt,
dass man andere Systeme
auf den Plan bringen konnte.
Diese soll auch wieder
der Bund bezahlen.
Man hat gemerkt,
dass es ein System braucht
und eine Excel-Liste nicht reicht.
Man kann auch einen gewissen
Forschungsgedanken integrieren.
Eine halbe Million Forschungskosten.
Wir hätten uns gewünscht, dass man
das System breitflächig einsetzt.
Dafür ist es konzipiert.
Denn das Virus interessiert sich
nicht für Kantonsgrenzen.
* Hohle, tickende Klänge *
Beim Bundesamt für Gesundheit
zeigen sich die Folgen
der unterschiedlichen Systeme.
Herr Kim,
wie zufrieden sind Sie aktuell
mit Tempo und Qualität
der gesammelten Daten
des Contact Tracing
der ganzen Schweiz und aller Kantone?
Ganz ehrlich:
Ich kann es Ihnen nicht sagen.
Wir wissen momentan nicht,
was die Kantone im Contact Tracing
aktuell konkret an Daten sammeln.
Sie sind in einem gewissen Blindflug?
Wir haben momentan von den Kantonen
diese detaillierten Daten nicht.
D.h.: Der Bund weiss zu wenig
über die Übertragungswege des Virus.
Eine nationale Datenbank soll im
Verlauf des Oktobers in Betrieb sein.
Warum erst ein halbes Jahr
nach dem milliardenteuren Lockdown?
Letztendlich, weil alle Parteien -
sowohl wir vom Bund
wie auch die kantonalen Behörden -
mit ihren eigenen Problemchen
zu tun hatten.
Der Bund finanziert auch
das Contact-Tracing-System SORMAS,
mit 700'000 Fr.
Im Moment sind es 15 oder 16 Kantone.
Noch mal: Wieso keine Verordnung?
Wenn man viel Geld in SORMAS pumpt,
wieso gibt es dann keine Verordnung,
dass es alle Kantone nutzen sollen?
Ich weiss nicht, ob es
juristisch möglich gewesen wäre.
Aber aus psychologischer Sicht
wäre es sehr kontraproduktiv,
wenn Sie die Kantone
in dem Kontext zu etwas zwingen,
wenn sie selbst schon an Lösungen
arbeiten oder schon Lösungen haben.
Kantone sind eigene Staaten.
Jeder hat sein Gesundheitswesen und
behauptet die Herrschaft darüber.
Damit kämpft der Bund jetzt
in dieser Krisensituation.
Er hat mit vielen
kleinen Königen zu tun.
Christoph Zenger,
Professor für Gesundheitsrecht.
Er hat die Zusammenarbeit
von Bund und Kantonen
im Fall einer Epidemie untersucht.
Also ...
Krisentauglich
ist der Föderalismus nicht.
Für Schönwetterzeiten
ist er wunderbar geeignet,
aber für eine Krisenzeit nicht.
* Tickende, glockige Klänge *
(Stefan Trachsel) Hier dargestellt
bezüglich der Verantwortung:
die Bundesämter,
die zusammenarbeiten.
Das Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz
BABS für das Ressourcenmanagement.
Neckischer Name!
- Genau.
Der KSD SANKO
macht die Zuteilung der Materialien.
Die Armeeapotheke
lagert und beschafft sie.
Das BAG macht die Vorgaben.
ZIVI, das Bundesamt für
wirtschaftliche Landesversorgung,
die Armee, Fedpol, Führungsstab
Polizei und die Zollverwaltung,
das DEZA
und das Schweizerische Rote Kreuz.
Das ist ja Wahnsinn,
das sind zwölf Organisationen.
Wenn man
nach der Verantwortung fragt,
wieso z.B. keine
oder zu wenige Lager vorhanden waren,
sieht man, dass es schwierig ist,
einen Verantwortlichen auszumachen,
weil viele Köche beteiligt sind.
Es sind bewusst
viele Köche beteiligt,
damit man abgestützt ist,
gerade in einer Krise.
Man möchte es nicht nur
auf einen Bereich beschränken.
Aber aus einer anderen Warte
sind schlussendlich
alle und niemand verantwortlich.
Es könnte so aussehen,
ist aber hier nicht der Fall.
Das BAG hat die Führung
beim Thema Pandemie.
Darf ich nachfragen?
Welches Amt
ist in der letzten Verantwortung,
ob man Lager hatte oder nicht,
wenn Sie eines nennen müssen?
Das kann ich nicht nennen.
In dieser Krise hat sich gezeigt,
dass eine Stärke der Schweiz
zum Nachteil wird:
nämlich dass möglichst viele Stellen
beteiligt sind und mitreden können,
sodass es gute Lösungen gibt.
Denn so fehlen
schnelle Entscheidungen
und niemand weiss,
wer eigentlich wofür zuständig ist.
D.h., die ganzen Strukturen der
Organisation sind völlig unscharf.
Das führt in einer Krise dazu, dass
jeder die Verantwortung abschiebt.
In der Krise haben wir die orga-
nisierte Verantwortungslosigkeit.
* Sanfte, schwebende Musik *
Es war der Bundesrat, der im März,
als die Zahl der Corona-Infizierten
steil anstieg,
die Führung übernahm
und den Lockdown anordnete.
Das hat man gut gemacht:
nicht zu früh und nicht zu spät,
und man hat schrittweise verschärft.
Bei der Lockerung
vermisse ich die Führung.
Hier beginnt diese
Verantwortungsdiffusion wieder.
Der Bundesrat sagt,
die Kantone seien verantwortlich.
Aber das
stimmt nach dem Gesetz nicht.
Denn die Führungsaufgabe
liegt trotzdem beim Bund.
Diese Führungsaufgabe des Bundesrats
vermisse ich in dieser Situation.
Genau das kann dazu führen, dass es
danach wieder zu einer Krise kommt.
Diese würde
viel schwieriger beherrschbar.
Hier arbeitet
der oberste Verantwortliche
im Fall einer Pandemie.
Enchantée.
- Ebenfalls.
Möchten Sie,
dass ich eine Maske trage?
Nein, nein, Sie sind weit genug weg.
Herr Bundesrat,
gestern eine neue Rekordzahl:
311 Neuinfektionen.
Wie haben Sie geschlafen?
Ja, gut, danke.
Aber klar, wir beobachten das
mit grosser Aufmerksamkeit.
Sie sind nicht beunruhigt?
Schon ein bisschen,
denn wir leben in Ungewissheit.
Während des Lockdowns
kam ja viel Lob.
Sie waren in der Führung,
Sie haben klar kommuniziert,
Massnahmen angeordnet.
Seit den Lockerungen ist viel mehr
Kritik und auch Wildwuchs da.
Der Bundesrat hat eine Maskenpflicht
im öffentlichen Verkehr verordnet,
aber nicht
in anderen geschlossenen Räumen.
Viele verstehen es nicht mehr,
halten sich nicht mehr
an die Massnahmen.
Experten sagen, die Führungsrolle
des Bundesrats fehle,
darum riskierten wir
eine zweite Welle.
Wir sind kein zentralistisches Land
und auch keine Diktatur.
Was wir im Februar und März
machen mussten,
um die Kontrolle über die Pandemie
wiederzuerlangen,
war sehr schwierig.
Es hat gut funktioniert
und war dann möglich,
zu einer normaleren Situation
zurückzufinden,
in der die Kantone
das Sagen haben müssen.
Aber das stimmt nicht ganz,
denn in der besonderen Lage
hat der Bund laut Epidemiengesetz
immer noch die Führungsrolle.
Darum sagen Kritiker, Sie nehmen
Ihre Führungsrolle nicht mehr wahr,
jetzt,
wo es schwieriger geworden ist.
Das ist nicht richtig.
Wir haben
eine präzise COVID-Verordnung,
die wir auch weiterentwickeln.
Auch die Grossveranstaltungen,
die fraglich sind,
werden wir
einigermassen einheitlich regeln.
Warum keine Maskenpflicht verordnen
für den ganzen geschlossenen Raum,
wie es auch das Ausland tut?
Weil es Orte gibt, wo es Sinn macht,
die Kantone
haben es dort auch verfügt.
An anderen Orten ist es im Moment
nicht absolut notwendig.
Aber ich sage das
mit aller Bescheidenheit.
Was heute gilt,
gilt morgen vielleicht nicht mehr.
Das darf man nicht vergessen.
- Ist es auch schwierig für Sie?
Es ist die Bewältigung einer Krise,
es ist eine andere Welt.
In einem Interview
zum fehlenden Vorrat an Schutzmasken
sagte der Gesundheitsminister:
Es ist nicht am Bund, Reserven
für die ganze Bevölkerung zu haben.
Es war nie so gedacht.
Im Epidemiengesetz aber steht:
"Der Bundesrat
stellt die Versorgung der Bevölkerung
mit den wichtigsten zur Bekämpfung
übertragbarer Krankheiten
geeigneten Heilmitteln sicher."
Soweit die Wirtschaft
keine Lager anlegt.
Zu den Heilmitteln
gehören auch Schutzmasken.
Ja, Heilmittel ... Nein,
Schutzmasken sind keine Heilmittel.
So steht es in der Botschaft.
Ich kann sie Ihnen zeigen.
Die Botschaft des Bundesrates.
- Ja, ja, wissen Sie ...
"Zu den wichtigsten Heilmitteln ...
unverzichtbare Arzneimittel
und wichtige Medizinprodukte
wie Schutzmasken."
Deswegen hatten wir Schutzmasken.
- Wir hatten zu wenige.
Nein, wir hatten welche.
Aber es ist auch klar geregelt ...
Diese ganze Diskussion
über die Vergangenheit
werden wir schon mal führen.
Wir sind jetzt aber
in der Bewältigung einer Krise.
Ich vermute, dass Bundesrat Berset
sehr genau weiss,
wer verantwortlich ist.
Er gilt als absolut dossiersicher,
sehr anspruchsvoll,
was die internen Informationen
angeht.
Man nennt ihn Roi Soleil,
der alles wissen will
über seine Untertanen im Bundesamt.
Der Sonnenkönig?
- Ja.
Ist es auch ein bisschen unangenehm
für Sie, zu sagen:
"Ich als Gesundheitsminister
bin für den Pandemieplan zuständig
und hätte mehr Verantwortung
für die Lager übernehmen sollen"?
Wissen Sie, dass wir nach der Krise
eine Analyse machen
und feststellen müssen, dass einige
Punkte nicht in Ordnung waren,
dass wir daraus lernen werden,
ist selbstverständlich.
Das ist das Minimum,
das man erwarten kann.
Und Sie persönlich?
- Auch, das ist klar.
Und nicht nur für mich, für alle.
Vor 13 Jahren
waren wir besser vorbereitet:
2007 kaufte der Bund diese Reserve
von 30 Mio. Hygienemasken.
Das war vor der Schweinegrippe.
Wer das Haus verlässt, müsste
im Pandemiefall eine Maske tragen?
In gewissen Situationen sicher, z.B.
in öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln,
in Lebensmittelgeschäften,
das ist fast offensichtlich.
Überall dort,
wo Menschen in Kontakt kommen.
Geht es darum,
dass ich nicht erkranke
oder dass andere
wegen mir nicht erkranken?
Es geht um beides. Es geht darum,
solche Masken zu tragen.
Denn man kann das Virus schon über-
tragen, bevor man selbst krank ist.
Deshalb ist es sinnvoll,
dass alle eine tragen.
Wir wiederholen dasselbe, das wir
schon seit Wochen wiederholen:
Schutzmasken
sind sehr wenig wirksam,
wenn sie in der allgemeinen
Bevölkerung getragen werden.
Im Moment sind sie weltweit
ein knappes Gut.
Deshalb wird nach wie vor
wirklich davon abgeraten,
diese Schutzmasken
in der Öffentlichkeit zu tragen.
Aber auch bei der Schweinegrippe
kam der Bund unter Beschuss.
Grüezi. Diese Pandemie kommt
und sie ist so ansteckend,
dass sie die halbe Schweiz
ins Bett legen könnte.
Wir gehen davon aus,
dass bis 2 Mio. Menschen
in der Schweiz erkranken könnten.
Es wird ein zu grosser Hype gemacht.
Panikmacherei.
- Hysterie der Pharmaindustrie.
Die Schreckensszenarien
sind nicht eingetreten.
Das Bundesamt für Gesundheit
entwarnt.
Zurück bleibt viel zu viel Impf-
stoff, den der Bund bestellt hat.
Ich bin der Meinung,
dass unsere Prognosen
nicht vollständig falsch waren.
Nach 2009, 2010
ist nichts mehr passiert.
Man sass auf diesen Lagern,
musste abbauen,
es wurde Material vernichtet.
Wie kam es zu diesem Druck,
die Lager herunterzufahren?
Darüber weisst du gut Bescheid.
- Ja.
Es war so: Man sagte ...
Wie viel muss man an Lager haben?
Man tat sich schwer mit Berechnen.
Geht es los, hat man
einen viel grösseren Tagesverbrauch.
Im Alltag
wird man es wohl nicht los.
Vom Bundesmaskenlager
waren nach der Schweinegrippe
noch rund 13 Mio. übrig.
Die Ware könne nicht
umgeschlagen werden und verfalle,
schrieb das Bundesamt
für wirtschaftliche Landesversorgung.
Darum werde das Lager nicht erneuert.
Anders klingt es beim BAG:
Das Lager sei noch in Diskussion.
Wieso sagte niemand,
der Bund sei in der Verantwortung
und müsse das zahlen?
Wir müssten es uns leisten,
dass ein Lager verfällt.
Ja, Finanzen
haben wohl eigene Gesetze.
Es gibt gar nicht viele gute Ideen.
Wir haben die Schuldenbremse,
der Bund, der einige Jahre
schwarze Zahlen geschrieben hat.
All das sind Rahmenbedingungen,
die es schwierig machen, zu sagen,
man müsse die Kasse öffnen als Bund,
um in die Bresche zu springen.
Oberfeldarzt Andreas Stettbacher.
Er verantwortete die ersten
Notfallbeschaffungen für die Armee.
Die Situation war prekär.
* Tickende, glockige Klänge *
Task-Force-Sitzung
des Bundesamts für Gesundheit.
Es ist der 13. März.
Stettbacher meldet:
"Vorrätig ein Maskenbestand
von etwa zweieinhalb Wochen".
Und:
Masken würden "weltweit eingekauft".
Herr Stettbacher konnte melden, dass
man eine Bestellung aufgegeben hat
über 50 Mio. Hygienemasken.
Das war am 16. März.
Soweit ich informiert bin, wären sie
aus Ägypten angeliefert worden.
Auf Nachfrage habe der Händler
aber nicht beweisen können,
dass er die Masken in Kairo
tatsächlich an Lager habe.
Zu riskant, befand das VBS,
und brach das Geschäft ab.
... dass sie aus diesem Grund aus
dem Vertrag zurücktreten mussten.
Es kamen keine Masken? - Nein,
das hat leider nicht geklappt.
Das war sicher
eine Riesenenttäuschung.
* Einzelne Klaviertöne *
Unsere Recherchen zeigen:
Das Schweizerische Rote Kreuz SRK
war ein wichtiger Helfer
bei den Beschaffungen des Bundes.
Notfalllogistiker Thomas Büeler:
Eigentlich hilft er
bei Krisen in Entwicklungsgebieten.
Plötzlich aber
war die Krise in der Heimat.
Ich wurde in dem Sinn überrascht,
wie schnell es geht
und wie wenig es braucht,
um unser System
an gewisse Grenzen zu bringen.
Denn es war keine Grosskatastrophe
wie nach einem Erdbeben.
Wir sind sicher
nicht sehr katastrophentauglich,
das ist meine persönliche Meinung.
Wir sind von den Prozessen
und der Organisation her
haben wir sicher
ein sehr hohes Niveau erreicht.
Die Umkehrseite ist, dass
ein solches System sehr fragil ist,
sehr abhängig ist.
Wenn einmal
eine der Komponenten wegfällt,
bricht ein solches System
sehr oft zusammen.
Als der Bund Mitte März
den 50-Mio.-Masken-Auftrag
aus Ägypten stornieren musste,
war das SRK schon viel weiter.
* Piepen *
Es hatte 20 Mio. Hygienemasken
in China für den Bund gekauft.
Organisiert durch das weltweite
Netzwerk des Roten Kreuzes.
Anfang April
wurde der erste Flieger beladen.
Der Hauptunterschied ist sicher,
dass wir durch das Netzwerk
sehr schnell
an Produzenten herankommen.
Während eine Behörde oder der Bund
diese Kontakte
erst richtig aufbauen musste.
Das sind natürlich zwei Welten,
die aufeinandertreffen:
Wir können
sehr agil und schnell agieren.
Auch in der Entscheidungsfindung
haben wir natürlich
viel weniger Stellen,
die mitentscheiden müssen.
16. März, Sitzung
beim Bundesamt für Gesundheit.
Thomas Büeler sagt,
er habe ein Angebot
von 2 Mio. FFP2-Masken für Spitäler
unterbreitet.
Weil diese Masken teuer sind,
brauchte er eine Vorauszahlung.
Die gesetzliche Grundlage dafür wurde
aber erst am 21. März geschaffen.
Gemäss SRK verfiel das Angebot.
Später konnte Thomas Büeler noch mal
18 Mio. FFP2-Masken anbieten.
Sagte der Bund dann, er greife zu?
Nein,
sie nahmen das Angebot mal auf.
Es geht immer um sehr viel Geld.
Da wird genau abgewogen,
ob man das viele Geld
in so kurzer Zeit
einfach sprechen kann.
Im Krisen- oder Katastrophenfall
hat man diese Zeit nicht.
Wusste Ihr Kontaktmann
der Armeeapotheke,
dass er nur 3 Std. Zeit hat?
Ah, ja!
Unseren Kontaktpersonen waren diese
Zeitdauern genauso bewusst wie uns.
Sie haben es einfach
durch das System -
ich kann
nur diesen Begriff benutzen -
nicht zeitnäher hingebracht.
Aber es dauerte etwa vier Tage.
Bis Sie eine Antwort hatten?
- Ja, genau.
Und dann?
- Dann sind solche Aufträge weg.
Die Armee sagt,
man habe nicht sofort kaufen können,
weil die Beschaffer noch
auf den Bundeskredit warteten.
Später aber habe man eine Anzahlung
für 10 Mio. FFP2-Masken
des gleichen Händlers
ans Rote Kreuz geleistet.
Diese Ware habe jedoch
nicht geliefert werden können.
Das Rote Kreuz bot seine Masken
zum Selbstkostenpreis, ohne Gewinn.
Die weltweite Notlage rief
aber auch Goldgräber auf den Plan.
Etwa die Firma Emix Trading.
Sie hat dem Bund eine halbe Million
FFP2-Masken geliefert.
Hier ihr ehemaliger Geschäftssitz,
in einer Villa am Zürichberg.
Hinter Emix
stehen zwei Jungunternehmer,
früher im Vorstand der Jungen SVP
Zürich, hier abgedeckt im Bild.
Auch das Kantonsspital Glarus
kaufte bei Emix ein.
Sie sagten, sie hätten pro FFP2-Maske
7.90 Fr. bezahlt.
Das sei
ein heruntergehandelter Preis,
die Jungunternehmer
hätten 8.95 Fr. verlangt.
Auch der Bund zahlte rund 8.90 Fr.
und sagt,
zu Beginn
habe nur Emix liefern können.
Die FFP2-Masken des SRK
hätten 4.20 Fr. gekostet.
Ich war nicht Teil
dieser Beschaffung,
aber das ist
ein sehr sportlicher Preis.
Anfang April
hat Emix den Geschäftssitz
ins steuergünstige Zug verlegt.
Die Firma sagt,
sie habe rund 2 Mrd. Umsatz
mit dem Maskenverkauf im EU-Raum
gemacht.
Insider sprechen von einem Gewinn
in der Höhe von Dutzenden Millionen.
Emix kommentiert das nicht.
Es ist ein freier Markt.
- Ja, genau.
In der Krise
gehen die Preise durch die Decke.
Gleichzeitig hat man mit der Not
von Menschen ein Geschäft gemacht.
Die Not von Menschen auszunutzen,
ist der Fokus
aufs falsche Problem gelenkt.
Ja, in einer Krise
sind Menschen in Not.
Aber was nahm man
in der Vorbereitung in Kauf,
in der man viele Kosten optimiert
und Strukturen heruntergefahren hat?
Eine ganze Geschichte
ist davor passiert,
was erst
in eine solche Situation führt.
Schauen wir uns die Geschichte davor
genauer an:
Wieder führt der Weg zur
wirtschaftlichen Landesversorgung.
Sie ist auch zuständig
für den Basisvorrat an FFP2-Masken
für Spitäler.
Unter Pflichtlagern hat der Bund
rund 170'000 dieser Masken.
Sehr wenig für die ganze Schweiz.
Warum?
Die Masken sind bewusst
für das Gesundheitswesen.
Deshalb ist die benötigte Menge
nicht beliebig gross.
Wenn der Bund keine Masken mehr hat,
woher bekommt er sie?
Grundsätzlich gehen wir davon aus,
dass das Pflichtlager da ist,
um im Krisenfall
den Bedarf zu decken.
Aber: Bereits im Pandemieplan
von 2013 steht,
die Mengen des Pflichtlagers seien
"zur Deckung des Pandemiebedarfs
bei Weitem unzureichend".
Ich sagte nicht,
das Pflichtlager allein reiche.
Doch, das haben Sie gesagt.
Dass ein Pflichtlager reicht,
um den Bedarf zu decken,
der auf uns zukommt.
Aber immer in der Meinung,
dass die Institutionen
eine eigene Lagerhaltung haben.
Die hat man empfohlen.
Man weiss nicht, was da ist.
So war es
im Pandemieplan vorgesehen.
So haben Sie es nicht gesagt.
In diesen paar Minuten -
es waren 5 oder weniger -
konnte man nicht
in diese Detailtiefe gehen.
Uns interessiert aber
die Detailtiefe.
Warum waren nur
170'000 Atemschutzmasken an Lager?
Das Gesundheitswesen kostet uns
über 80 Mrd. jährlich.
2014.
Damals schreibt Ueli Haudenschild:
Die Importeure von Atemschutzmasken
würden "keine Bereitschaft" zeigen,
ihre Lager
für eine Pandemie aufzustocken.
Darum fordert er
die "Einführung einer
obligatorischen Pflichtlagerhaltung"
bei der Wirtschaft.
Zwei Jahre später:
Die Maskenimporteure
sind weiterhin nicht bereit,
ihre Lager
im grossen Stil aufzustocken.
Also schreibt das Amt:
Pflichtlager seien
"für die Problematik der Pandemie
nicht geeignet".
Die Beamten nehmen einen
anderen Kostenträger ins Visier:
"Die Kantone" sollen die Versorgung
von Spitälern und Heimen
sicherstellen.
Diese aber wehren sich und sagen,
"dass der Bund die Kosten" für Masken
im Pandemiefall zu tragen habe.
Das Amt widerspricht:
"Eine Kostenbeteiligung
durch den Bund ist nicht vorgesehen."
Wieder ein Jahr später:
Die Beamten kapitulieren.
Spitäler und Heime sollten "in ihrer
Eigenverantwortung" Vorräte anlegen.
Lager für drei Monate, "im Sinne
von Empfehlungen" zu verstehen.
Sind Sie nicht den Weg
des geringsten Widerstands gegangen?
Sie und Ihr Amt sind zuständig,
dass wir im Krisenfall
eine Vorsorge haben,
aber wir hatten sie nicht.
Im Nachhinein betrachtet, wurde es
vielleicht zu wenig umgesetzt.
So gesehen kam die Pandemie
einfach etwas zu früh.
Im Pflegeheim Aergera gab es nur
einen Maskenvorrat für drei Wochen.
Statt drei Monaten, wie der Bund
im Pandemieplan empfiehlt.
Nein, das habe ich ...
Nein, den kannte ich nicht.
Eigentlich war es eine Holschuld
von mir, die ich verpasst habe.
Ich hatte damals andere Prioritäten,
als das zu holen.
Ich wusste: Die Lieferkette ist
gewährleistet, da passiert nichts.
Wenn man von Anfang an eine
Verordnung, eine Vorschrift macht,
hat man nichts als Widerstand
von den Institutionen,
die eine Freiwilligkeit wollen.
Das ist ein beliebter Ausweg
der Verwaltung:
Wenn man sich
die Finger nicht verbrennen will
oder genug hat vom Gegendruck,
der kommt,
gibt man einfach Empfehlungen ab.
Im schlimmsten Fall,
wenn es zur Krise kommt, sagt man:
"Wir haben es ja empfohlen. Warum
habt ihr nicht selbst überlegt?"
Das ist eine Haltung,
die für ein Bundesamt nicht geht.
Es ist verantwortlich
für den Gesetzesvollzug.
Wenn es mit den Kantonen
und Spitälern keine Lösung findet,
muss es beim Amtschef
Rückendeckung suchen und sagen:
"Gesetz nicht erfüllbar,
niemand macht es."
Oder: "Wir brauchen Budget,
um es selbst zu machen."
Gingen Sie zu Herrn Meier,
dem Amtschef,
oder zu Bundesrat Schneider-Ammann,
weil Sie keine Lösung hatten und
man mit dem BAG eine suchen müsse?
Auch die Finanzierung.
"Zahlen w i r das?"
Nein, so funktioniert es nicht.
Weil die Landesversorgung
a priori nicht bezahlt
für die Pflichtlagerhaltung.
- Wie kommen Sie darauf?
Wir finanzieren keine Lager.
- Das stimmt so nicht.
Im alten Artikel 18
des Landesversorgungsgesetzes steht:
"Der Bund kann zur Ergänzung von
Pflichtlagern eigene Vorräte anlegen,
wenn Eigentümer von Lagern
nicht imstande sind,
selbst genügend Lager
bereitzustellen".
Das steht seit 1983 im Gesetz.
Ich w...
Ich weiss nicht, welche Optionen ...
Ähm ...
Wir reden von der Gesetzesvariante
von 2014 ...
... möglich gewesen wären,
um eine Zusatzfinanzierung
durch den Bund zu machen.
Die Erfahrung zeigt einfach:
Wenn die Krise relativ weit weg ist,
ist es sehr schwierig,
entsprechende Finanzen zu bekommen.
Geschätzte Damen und Herren,
die Armeeapotheke
wurde Mitte März damit beauftragt,
knappe und wichtige
medizinische Güter
für das gesamte Gesundheitswesen
zu beschaffen.
Ich weiss noch: Der Kollege
der Armeeapotheke rief mich an.
Er sagte, ich müsse unbedingt
die Pressekonferenz schauen.
Ich würde mich sicher sehr freuen.
Er sagte nur das.
Im Sinne einer Anschubversorgung
liefert die Armeeapotheke
ab nächster Woche
während zwei Wochen
täglich 1 Mio. Hygienemasken
an führende Detailhändler.
Ja, das sind sicher Masken
vom Roten Kreuz.
Sie sagt aber, der Bund.
Das sind schon Masken vom
Roten Kreuz, von denen sie spricht.
Es wäre sicher schön gewesen,
wenn das SRK in diesem Atemzug ...
... "von Bund und SRK zusammen",
wenn es erwähnt worden wäre.
Unterdessen
wurden diese Masken kritisiert,
weil sie falsch deklariert waren.
Das SRK sagt, man habe die Masken
in China und in der Schweiz
prüfen lassen, für die Bevölkerung
sei der Schutz gewährleistet.
(Viola Amherd) Zusätzlich haben
der Bund und der Kanton Zürich
zwei Maschinen für die Produktion
von FFP2-Masken gekauft.
Sie treffen in diesen Stunden
am Flughafen Zürich ein
und werden ab spätestens Mitte Mai
die Produktion aufnehmen.
Wir rechnen mit dem Betriebsstart
ungefähr in der zweiten Aprilhälfte.
Die angestrebte Produktionsmenge von
täglich 80'000-100'000 FFP2-Masken
leistet einen wesentlichen Beitrag,
dass in der Schweiz
genügend Masken verfügbar sind.
Mitte Juni: Noch ist keine Maske
ausgeliefert worden.
Die Zürcher Maschine
ist noch gar nicht in Betrieb.
Und die Bundesmaschine
kämpft mit Kinderkrankheiten.
Was ist das Problem?
- Läuft sie jetzt wieder?
Der Nasenclip
ist irgendwie ausgehängt.
Dann gerät der Nasenclip
in die Maschine.
Er ist gekommen.
- Jetzt kommt er gerade.
Jetzt läuft es perfekt.
Aber der kann manchmal ausfädeln.
Dann muss man ausschalten
und ihn neu einfädeln.
Wie erklärt sich
die Informationspolitik
der Politikerinnen?
Wir haben zu keiner Zeit
einen früheren Liefertermin
angegeben als Ende April.
Natalie Rickli hat das evtl. falsch
verstanden, das kann ja passieren.
Sie hat dann kommuniziert,
dass sie dann läuft.
Was die Politik genau gesagt hat,
wie die Kommunikation genau war,
kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Haben Sie sich nicht abgesprochen?
Sie sind von der Herstellerfirma.
Ich habe nicht
mit der Politik geredet.
Wir haben einfach eine Maschine
verkauft an Bund und Kantone.
Wir haben einen Vertrag.
Zu Beginn gingen wir davon aus,
viel schneller in Betrieb zu gehen.
Wann wollte man sie zu Beginn
in Betrieb nehmen? Was war angedacht?
Mitte Mai.
Wir waren ehrlich überzeugt:
Per Mitte Mai schaffen wir das.
Jetzt sind wir etwa einen Monat
oder fünf Wochen verzögert.
Wir hatten mit der Maschine
mehr Probleme als erwartet.
Schutzmasken made in Switzerland:
Seit Mitte Juli läuft die Produktion.
FLAWA hat die Maschinen
vom Staat gekauft.
Im Gegenzug nehmen Bund
und Kanton Zürich 5 Mio. Masken ab.
Nur: Unabhängig vom Ausland
sind wir trotzdem nicht.
Das Rohmaterial nämlich stammt
aus Deutschland, Polen und China.
Es ist entscheidend,
dass die Schweiz einen Weg findet
in eine gewisse Unabhängigkeit.
Aber man muss auch Mass halten
und sich fragen,
welcher Teil auch Sinn macht.
Eine totale Unabhängigkeit müssen
wir uns wohl einfach abschminken.
Definitiv.
* Melancholische Klavierakkorde *
Die Krise
hat auch die Pflegeheime gelehrt:
Es braucht Lager - grosse Lager.
Ah, Lilian!Hast du gesehen?
Wir haben Masken bekommen.
Ja, ich habe oben
zwei grosse Kartons gesehen.
Das sind die 5'000,
die du bestellt hast. - Ja, genau.
Ich habe noch 10'000 bekommen.
- Ah, das ist super!
Jetzt haben wir 16'000-17'000,
also für drei Monate.
Super! Danke, tschüss!
Die Kosten der Lager
dürfen nicht mehr
als totes Kapital gesehen werden,
das gewinnbringender
eingesetzt werden kann.
Jetzt bin ich extrem gespannt
auf diese Anlage.
Beim Ethanol hat der Bundesrat
unterdessen beschlossen,
wieder ein Reservelager anzulegen.
Und alcosuisse-Chef Florian Krebs
hat die letzten Monate über versucht,
den fauligen Geruch
des Krisen-Ethanols zu verbessern.
* Monotone Klaviertöne *
Bleibt die Frage:
Wer soll künftig für die
Krisenvorsorge verantwortlich sein?
(Christoph Zenger) Man müsste
dem Bund die Möglichkeit geben,
direkt durchzugreifen
und direkt zu vollziehen,
den Spitälern Weisungen zu geben,
was sie vorrätig zu halten haben,
aber dass er das auch finanziert.
D.h., die Kantone wären im Krisen-
fall einer Pandemie aus dem Spiel.
Also ausgeschaltet?
- Ja.
Sie hätten nichts mehr zu sagen
und müssten nichts mehr bezahlen.
Welche Chancen
geben Sie Ihrem Vorschlag,
dass die Kantone akzeptieren,
dass so etwas durchkommt?
Bis letzten Dezember
hätte ich ihm keine Chance gegeben.
Nach der Erfahrung mit der Krise
könnte ich mir vorstellen,
dass es mindestens
diskussionswürdig ist.
Wie soll sich die Schweiz auf eine nächste Versorgungskrise vorbereiten?
Wollen wir Wirtschaftsbereiche wie die Maskenproduktion oder die Medikamentenherstellung
zurück in unser Land holen?
Sind wir aber auch bereit, den Preis dafür zu zahlen?
Und wie tauglich ist unser föderales Gesundheitswesen, mit seinen vielen Akteuren,
wenn es um die Vorbereitung einer Krise geht?
Jetzt interessiert mich eure Meinung.
Schreibt alles in die Kommentare. Ich werde eure Fragen in einem Q&A beantworten.